this season of sex ed is brought to you
by lilo stick around until after the
episode to learn a little bit more
during the day like if we don't see each
other for like a day or two it's so nice
to like
you know just like hey like here's a
little boob pick like here's a little
sex to like keep you going
[Music]
do you enjoy a sexting yes it's like a
favorite hobby of mine
most of the time yes no like
i mean you kind of say little things
here and there
but i'm like by the time i got with my
partner it was no point
like girl just come over look up some
words
tell me just like what the text is that
comes up oh my god so the first
word let's just do sex ses
well if precautions are made there are
no reasons
for not having sex and those stockings
are so [__] sexy
just do the eggplant emoji
there's no way that people use that
oh my god yeah
with my boyfriend and i not only did i
use the eggplant emoji but i used
the water splash after it let's just
send
eggplant
[Laughter]
how do you feel about dick pics i see a
lot of
dick pic slender i don't think they're
as fun as guys think they are
it's always a mystery whenever i look at
a guy i'm like
can i get a dick pic from you just to
see the lighting has to be good your
room has to be clean
um your face should not be in it
it can't be like in your hand you know
when i get it i'm not like
ooh my opinion on dick pics is if you
want to send me one
then i'm going to send you my venmo and
then you have to pay me to see it and
then
i'll reply but you gotta pay me and see
it where's the weirdest place you've
ever sexted
i think i've done it on hikes a few
times i'm just going in the phones like
oh
probably like a therapist office
what trauma doesn't make you horny okay
this is gonna sound so bad but straight
up i did it
just for the story the vatican in italy
when you're in the vatican like what
else like do i look like i'm like in a
pride no i'm gonna send a text
i'm gonna send a text
do you ever lie when you are sexting um
doesn't everybody
as far as i'm concerned sexting is just
lying
nobody's completely honest if you're
completely honest it's boring
everyone's greedy you know you sexed to
get something
the thing that i want isn't nudes it's
just you know
affection what's the worst sex
you've ever gotten probably that it
wasn't
the person who said it was one time he
sent his dick and a strawberry shortcake
asking if they could like do like weird
stuff like with toes like asking if they
could suck my toes and i was like
that's not my thing how do you make the
first move and know notes the right time
i definitely have to get comfortable
with the person first you just
kind of have to go for it see if there's
pushback
and if not then just kind of keep seeing
where it goes
after like a month or so or maybe two
depending how we feel
and if we haven't seen each other in a
while then i'll probably
like maybe ask or we'll collaborate on
it and see like if it's a good idea or
not
would you consider sexting a form of
cheating
i would i definitely would even though
it may just be like a fantasy in
your head and all that you're still
thinking a lot about it
if you're like in a relationship with
someone and you are like talking about
sex with someone else i think
that even though you're not actually
doing it i think just talking about it
with someone else
is definitely a form of cheating perhaps
if it's like transactional or if it's a
job
then no because that's work but if it's
for like your own personal gain i think
it speaks to something that like
yeah maybe you're not getting in your
relationship do you delete nudes from
people you are no longer talking to
or do you keep them unless i'm like in a
committed relationship i don't really
keep them to begin with because it's
usually like over snapchat i delete them
uh i feel like that's just invasion of
privacy i feel like when you're with
someone obviously like the consent is
there to have the nude
but once like the situation has been
evacuated
if you're holding on to those nudes i
feel like it's like
kind of like non-consensual in a way
yeah i've had people who've
kept them and sent them and to other
people
and so i definitely don't want that to
happen like any other person because i
know how crappy that feels
have you ever sexted with a stranger or
someone you only knew online
yeah i did it with a stranger and i
definitely uh learned my lesson from
that
was not a good experience yeah it's very
dangerous to do that
so the experience i had was that this
older like person was posing on this app
to be like kind of young
it's like an app for like minors you
know to like make friends and stuff
and so then i was like messaging them
and saying like there's no way you're 16
they're like
okay 18. i'm like no you don't look 18.
like please get off this app
and yeah and it ended up and they're
like okay but you texted me like you
have to like something about me
and i was like you know like they were
yeah they were pretty weird so uh
like three four years ago i get uh
like uh someone added me on snapchat i
didn't know who it was
and then i added them back because i was
like oh
why not just a new friend or whatnot and
then they sent me videos of them
very explicit videos and uh they're like
if you want more
send me your like stuff of you and
i was a sophomore in high school at the
time i was like oh yeah sure easy
um and then after
that endeavor uh they removed me from
snapchat or whatnot i didn't think too
much of it because i didn't really know
them
um and then about five months
later i find out that a kid in my grade
it was uh he played
like he catfished me and as as this
woman
and he kept my photos and videos
and send them to people in my high
school
[Music]
what is something that you want people
to kind of
learn or take away from this experience
yeah so i think sexting is a great way
to be close to a partner
um i just think that the internet is
definitely
there there's some good and bad things
to it and like
even regard like the disregarding like
sexy and just with everything
and uh just to really that that's just
the biggest thing like with me in
relationships it's just all about trust
and honesty
what's just like something you wish you
would learn
the communication is key and that's for
anything like anything in your life
whether it's sex or like
what do you want to eat you know i
always why i always
like read like cosmopolitan magazine
magazines on like snapchat
and they would always talk about like
female pleasure and uh
what female like what women think are
like hot sexy like what do they enjoy
and so that really made me like become
more comfortable with
all that stuff it's such a natural thing
that happens and like it's
okay and like every single person in
this world does it
and pregnancy and
stds all those things should just
totally be destigmatized and everyone
should talk about it
i had all these images projected onto me
of like okay if this happens you're bad
if this happens you're bad
and i wish i could just like tell my
like young self that like
chill out even if those things happen to
you you're gonna be fine you're gonna
say weird [__] for the first like
a hundred times um and yeah maybe it's
just
we're all so nervous to be like
vulnerable
and sexual and we shouldn't be
god this is embarrassing i know nothing
i have
no idea how we would use some of these
things
let's talk about that what is this it's
a shoe
this is a high heel
i do i do like this oh my god oh i think
this one has a sucker too
this one's cool because there's like a
little a little part for the
you know for the i'm just waiting for
the
okay and also hooks in so
cute it's very smooth very exciting it
feels like a phone case
like it it'll keep things safe it's not
gonna break so let's
do some cue cards we're just going to
read them
this is enigma from lilo with dual
stimulation
enigma is designed to place the most
experienced users with an orgasm
so intense it's not for everyone i love
the last line
that's strong i mean the design itself
is quite a statement this is so pretty
i like this color wowzers making clients
out of us
here your pleasure is your own and lilo
knows it educate yourself
about your own body and your own
pleasure first
in order to enjoy sharing it with a
partner go to lilo.com
to know more
[Music]
foreign